allora io vorrei semplicemente per
vedere questa tavola che è piena zeppa
di perché qui abbiamo anche un amico di
famiglia che sta imparando quando piange
ciao ciao signore signori panettone
artigianale e la grandezza
già la patente mi hanno chiesto se
volevo un passeggino ma secondo me
possiamo già andare di macchina 2020
ragazzi faccio vedere quello che si
vedrà
cioè sorretto sono a casa di luigi di
niente stiamo festeggiando
non so se mi senti auguri spero che
quest'anno possa essere pieno di
segnalazioni pieno di felicità pochino
meno rumoroso diamo ora che cosa fanno
anche gli altri ragazzi ci tenevo che
anche loro avessero un augurio che
quest'anno sia un pochino separati
no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no è bellissima atmosfera ragazzi mamma
mia il messaggio che mandiamo un
messaggio carino allora ormai siamo nel
2020 e il messaggio state sempre
indumenti rossi a capodanno e anche il
preservativo stavo per dire tragitto che
ovviamente sei un po più avidità di noi
che cosa consigli venendomi del 20
grazie così il preservativo
buongiorno buon 20 20 come state che
avete fatto di bello ieri sera devo dire
che mi sono parecchio divertita tanto
che
qualche balla il valzer sorgente che
cosine sempre una famiglia così un po
stramba io devo dire che ieri sera aveva
registrato un video molto carino della
festa che ho fatto di capodanno e che
video che è registrata in realtà
fondamentalmente soltanto dentro la mia
testa perché non avevi spinto il tasso
del cellulare quindi continuano solo a
girare con un telefono falsato ma che mi
serviva a poco oa niente comunque in
realtà ho pensato che anche se avessimo
andato il video ai miei cugini che
quest'anno siamo stati tutti un pò che
chi non farsi in fondamentalmente
sarebbe stato ricevuto tipo downer lei
in questa posizione post abbuffata di
cibo e quindi questo è per questo che
non lascia incentrato nella samp e voi
non sarà passato niente qua invece è
passato un po di tempo non so se mi
vedete che spesso sono una palla adesso
siamo tornati a roma
ho avuto una mezza un mezzo virus
intestinale che ho combattuto il giorno
dopo con una bella tagliata funghi e
parmigiano e adesso e fieri e le
patatine fritte e mozzarella in carrozza
e altre cose deliziose e adesso sto
provando la meraviglia scusate lo faccio
vedere meglio e adesso sto assaporando
il regalo che ho fatto saverio che è
meraviglioso anche piccole ma non me ne
ha regalato 6 fragranze diverse da
quelli oli naturali e l'acqua quindi
cioè con questo ci vado avanti
all'infinito togliamo gli occhiali che
sono solo riflesso un filtro fa i miei
occhi e volte e oltre a questo stiamo
togliendo finalmente sta albero di me e
posso dirlo io odio fare l'albero di
natale sta a me e al praticamente
togliere voi che questo studio potrà
tornare a essere minimo ordinato ho
scoperto di essere un pochino sì di con
l'ordine specialmente dopo che lotteri
caricando perché questa casa è stata un
tipo agra
per tanto tempo ogni giorno mi ha
aiutato e abbia motivo buttato una
quantità di roba inutile e da allora io
la tengo immacolata questa causa a
nievole stoccare i contributi che ho
fatto per appendere albero là sopra
tutte quelle che poi tagliata st iunco
io sto toccando il bookie perché
impazzisco per i buchi nelle pareti
vabbè lascia stare in quello che viene
coperto quello che roberto non fumare
poi sembra scappata di casa cioè dove
trovi uno che stupì buchi dovrà essere
sessuale in realtà proprio quelle con
angelini per tenute in mente la
cenerentola
signore e signori nel miracolo di un'ora
e mezza guardate una casa senza natale
guarda la meraviglia guarda l'ordine
guarda quanto ci aveva rotto e tutto
questo non sarebbe stato possibile senza
questa dolcezza la cagna libia che sta
mangiando mangiando e libri è che stava
male davvero
e quanto è buona l'epifania in famiglia
comunque davvero con diverse sen ascolto
mandaci roba era capito concentratissimi
disagi a fare per ma io sono venuto a
vedermi perché ho sentito un pubblico
delirante il pubblico 20 secondi locale
mary saluta ciao che sono poi chissà che
non essere ormai è di oggi un fallo da
tutti quei falli meri aspetta abbia
risposto vi dite
in che cosa conta ora praticamente voi
vi parlo al telefono è la verità se in
via tabacchi forse ma che fate di votate
da fare adesso sì per il rally
rispondere dal telefono delle domande
sugli altri e quindi fondamentalmente si
faceva klinzha e quindi sacri che a
breve giocherei con noi assolutamente
sempre alla fetta aspetta un attimo mi
riprendo di nuovo tra mary perché tocca
questo modo anche a me li prendi da di
bloccare aggiungi che a questo punto
siete
abbiamo aggiunto membri dei consigli a
chi non è di sperare che quanto facciamo
st stessa scegliete di quanto economia
il cap
quale sembrano pensate che io sono i
nuovi latore della festa del gioco e
naturale ha spiegato io dico sono un
amore lanciatori a prego io sono tornato
a casa sono sotto le mie belle copertine
riscaldarla tempio dire una cosa prima
di tutto scusate se questo video è stato
un pochino così raffazzonato però è
stata è stato un collegio di momenti di
queste vacanze dopo la fine del pasto
natale che comunque volevo condividere
sono dei pezzetti sembra più un pezzo
forte rubidio e rock di tutto ciò c'è
un'altra domanda e volevo fare ossia ma
se quest'anno inizia assestare un blog
settimanale potrebbe piacere come idea o
meglio il blog mastica bene l'ex nella
tua vita
fatemelo sapere nei commenti fino ad
allora vi mando ban sicilia prossimo
video e non so questo è un aperto visto
un po perdendo quei giorni sono nemmeno
idea di che già oggi